With respect to that,
I have to say that less than five
percent of Alzheimer Diseases are
genetic trust meter.
So 95 percent are not genetically
transmitted.
And uh,
generally speaking,
the ones that are genetically
transmitted,
the,
they tend to occur at earlier ages than
adult is not a general rule,
but more often people who have it
because of genetic reasons that a five
percent of the people population,
uh,
they have it at the earlier ages,
but it's only five percent
or less than five percent,
about five.
That number.
It's not that in China there is more
than America,
less than Europe.
There is more or less than here and
there,
but there are a particular population
that in a tigger circumstances that
could lead to dementia.
And,
uh,
because of,
the habits of those,
uh,
the population,
there are small groups of people.
For instance,
uh,
in the,
in the Pacific,
they were population.
They used to eat the brain of the dead
people.
And then they were transferring disease,
which one of the symptoms of the disease
was dementia and they were all
developing goodman's over there.
There was a higher incidence of dementia
just because of this habit of hitting
the brain of the people that were that
and therefore like an infectious
disease,
they were transferring the disease for
one,
two and higher incidents of people
affected.
This is once this was found in this
habits where it stopped,
then the incidents of disease became the
same as a,
with in other populations
in general.
You know,
if you look at our society,
there is not a population of people or
you know,
that is more affected by the loss of
memory.
It is a problem.
And that heats with aging.
So something related with the,
with aging.
And so as we age,
we get more memory,
more memory problem.
Obviously not all people are equal.
There are some one,
a better memory than others.
And uh,
and we do not know why some people have
a better memory than others.
I mean,
we say that,
uh,
that,
um,
they,
uh,
free keep ourselves and our brand
exercises just like a muscle,
a gen,
we tend to have memory problems,
less memory problems.
So it kind of protective the activity of
mental activity.
Even some people think even physical
activity,
it could be protected against the memory
loss,
the loss of memory.
Um,
that's what,
uh,
I have to say I'm obviously,
there are diseases which are associated.
The one of the most typical one is
Alzheimer's disease which are associated
with the loss of memory and a
hardass but are of less relevance and
less
and the characteristic symptoms of our
symptom of Alzheimer's disease,
which is really whole market disease,
is the loss of what we call short term
memory.
So that's how the disease starts.
Actually.
It's people who can not remember what
they just did,
the justice,
a very short term memory loss and that's
last for very,
very long time.
And progressively the memory problem get
worse and worse.
Um,
and only at the late stage of Alzheimer
disease,
it's also longterm memory is affected.
But the major characteristic of
Alzheimer disease,
which is a very widespread disease in
the population patient at old age is the
loss of short term memory.